together stroll I love that line from
this trailer alright there's a new rise
no dawn
there's a new dawn of the Planet of the
Apes trailer so I figure alright I'll do
a video if it's worth talking about
I watched it hey guess what we're
talking about that's right spoiler alert
this luckily it's only the second dawn
of the Planet of the Apes trailer it's
not like x-men Days of Future past in
the amazing spider-man 2 where I had to
stop watching him because I wanted a
little bit to be left of the imagination
by the time I saw the movie I'd say this
movie looks pretty good the setting is I
mean everything looks like [ __ ] it looks
like post-apocalyptic already I thought
all right so the Apes just kind of owned
face and they ripped through town and
now they're on the top of the food chain
which they kind of are remember in the
last trailer Gary Oldman's like we spent
four years fighting the virus and then
for fighting each other so you think all
right maybe the humans did this to
themselves you gonna get the feeling in
this trailer that the Apes ground out a
little piece of property there look we
just exist here no one knows we're here
but this dude is just walking along the
woods like lolly lolly lolly get your
adverbs ahead oh [ __ ] he sees a couple
of aids he just whips out a gun he whips
out his piece and the Apes aren't having
that and the dudes like we don't mean
you any harm so I'm like okay they know
apes are smart means among the whole
virus thing in the subsequent eight
years past they probably did a little
ass-kicking themselves and among the
Apes civilization I mean they're reading
the writing Caesars talking a lot more I
like the way he talks he talks like he
did at the end of the last movie which
is a spoiler it's kind of a bummer I
know it dude in particular he has not
seen the first Rise of the Planet of the
Apes movie night almost told him about
the scene you know the scene oh love
that [ __ ] I stopped I was like you know
what watch the movie it'll be worth it
obvious trail who's gonna know they talk
so this is the effect is gonna be lost
sometimes you just gotta go ahead with
the trailer and just put [ __ ] in there
that's gonna spoil the previous movie I
get it I don't like the way Ceasar talks
because you know he's advanced he thinks
you get it there's one dudes like Caesar
you gotta go he's all go where yes
because you're smart doesn't mean your
voice box is physically evolved all
sound so I like that like that they
separate that you would think no [ __ ]
but it'd be so easy for a director to
feel like now they talk all like to us
and know just wouldn't be realistic to
me but you see the main dude in this
trailer so believes that apes and humans
can co-exist and everything can be fine
obviously this dude he's not from
America because if Republicans and
Democrats can't do it apes and humans
they're not doing it you can tell a lot
of people of
suffered loss at the hands of the Apes
oh yeah obviously they have done a lot
of ass-kicking themselves gary oldman
slides you know they're gonna turn on
you they can't be trusted they're
animals there's this one scene where all
the Apes are here and all the humans are
there and they got their guns on them
you feel like it's gonna be let that
shower scene from the rock everyone's
gonna be at each other and there's gonna
be guns and guns and one person's gonna
get a little trigger-happy and one human
you know it's gonna be humans gonna pop
a shot and after that the war is on it's
not going to be pretty at all says the
last shot of this trailer oh my god
Cesar is you can tell Caesar doesn't
want to fight he just wants to live in
his little year topia he's made for
himself because obviously caesar has
played civilization he has the one
little civilization because he's playing
as Gandhi and he just wants to be over
there and just have one little camp
where they can be left alone so then
when it all goes down and people start
[ __ ] out he then goes all right you
let me get on the war paint let me be an
awesome military leader let me show you
how it's done let me show you how we get
to the charlton heston segment of this
Planet of the Apes story Caesar got to
do Caesar got to do this movie looks
great I'm having flashbacks to 2011 we
had x-men first class and raisa Planet
of the Apes in summer 2011 now we have
x-men days that feature pass and Dawn at
the Planet of the Apes it looks like it
could be really sweet sequels happening
better could be really disappointing two
sequels that will make us all cry I
don't presume to know what's going to
happen all I'm saying is I'm looking
forward to this summer it's in the new
trailer to dawn of the Planet of the
Apes have you seen it what did you think
about it ever you thought comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you